hi guys and welcome to a game swap plays
life is strange episode 2 hmm we're
gonna do two of these videos were me
instead play through the whole of the
second part of life strangers called at
a time ironic because we could look at a
time to play this yeah you will take
time you were taking a guess at the name
and you got it wrong you should have
been pew pay because the first one was
chrysalis and then pew pay and then you
emerge as a beautiful butterfly right
like camera isn't that life that light
life is a beautiful butterfly I'm said
by the way this is cam we're going to be
going off cams choices from episode one
by the way oh I was a good Samaritan I
wasn't really my god I can't wait to
tell you about your things like let
people draw you well let's let's find
out all about this let's go straight on
to the beginning of what city you pay
let's call the pupae out of time that's
it oh man I literally had this this
morning didn't wake up and a girl's dorm
with you teddy was there though what it
sounds like you be saying we made almost
exactly opposite choices I think so yeah
um but what do you think happened to
Rachel amber let's well this beautiful
intro plays what's your prediction see I
think she's been abducted I don't think
she's dead I did you got abducted I i
like to think maybe she's got similar
powers to max and is cruising around
time and space like some kind of doctor
who s Time Lord I'll be so good if
that's not the story maybe I've got a
shirt change it I like you've already
actually made your first choice cam by
not getting up oh can I do that oh yeah
yeah no I missed loads loads and loads
of things in the last episode apparently
because we were setting the choices for
this it was like did you do this I was
like dope you notice this I was like no
so I'm taking time to look around let's
look my thinking my appearance in the
main room hello zombie face this is what
happens when you research quantum
physics on me don't I know so can I know
one thing I know you didn't do and I did
and I'm gonna insist that you do is go
in water that damn plan I was not
looking so good I can bring you back I
hold the power over life itself would
you take the share with you laptop uh
yeah I don't want to talk about that
right now okay photos of myself i else i
meant to replicate my normal appearance
I had a really tricky timing University
so if you haven't played this before
what cam
did there would start rewinding time
some basically the entire crux of the
game so far that Max has discovered she
has the power to at least haha partially
rewind time warner Warren Melissa can
you stand over there um okay max if that
makes you happy love that this is the
only person you ever worn oh man
Alyssa's like a magnet for stuff to the
head yeah we should use that power later
I use that power and you should totes
time you don't even notice camera give
me money hello good you're the boss see
Kate likes me as I saved her thanks
again her standing up Percy said I
needed that needed that said sorry
she'll be better in the long run that
guy has issues see what I've done is
I've made my life less strain simpler if
you're making lots of enemies I'm making
more enemies that rely on me for fewer
things more enemies you can yeah the
less favorite dude exactly right I think
it's awesome you set a tongue record on
video uberti site you may be sorry
someday Oh boohoo I'm sorry you're a
viral [ __ ] I'm sure she had fun let's
leave the link to Kate's video so
everybody gets a chance to see her in
action Wow school on your elbow comport
/ kissing all right arrays Robin oh I
can stop one person from watching it
it's worth it um we get people i'm so
proud again hallett Spencer I'm good to
flow thanks that's that's awful that is
awful no I think we're kind of done with
things we can do in here okay rachel is
a [ __ ] let's remember that that's
important supporting information hello
stranger what's happening dinner
everything cool between you and Juliet
oh yeah so wait was she the one accused
of sexting activity yes and I only went
in principle something they call music
today is that Trevor asked me to the
halloween shindig that's awesome Dana oh
sad we're gonna go to the bar e um i
would definitely guy think why not yeah
why not why the [ __ ] not if i hate it i
can always go back she was like don't
say that the spirit max that's the
spirit ready for a ring it does sound
fun seb did you did you find anything in
this room when you played this before oh
that's a good question I don't think I
explored that thoroughly because she was
watching me and I found that kind of
unnerving let's just use
computer for the left of them yeah no I
say that out loud dork okay they're like
I mean you know it really check her out
and tell me what she's like do you
believe everything you see like Zachary
sexting Dana too shy now I feel like an
ass that's cuz you own ass thanks for
finding out the truth yesterday you have
a good heart Max and I won't watch
Kate's video anymore anymore surely what
you want you baby watch it talk to you
go to on leap yeah that's ready I gotta
take it off my screen saver haha you are
still going the wrong way sir I'm
looking around the Stella's room it's
not gonna tell Israel dog again clearly
not a morning person you got such it
jack really not I'm worried this is how
I got the University of clearly not on
morning okay she's clearly not a morning
person I think she's not a morning
person uh red rolling night man very
good um such a jerk Taylor is no doubt
being fit such it is no doubt being led
around I think you should ruin Brooke to
Doug's usual very late break duck duck
for the love of God did you get a chance
to fly her dream science no cuz i really
wanted to you and i was like i'm really
into this she was just can't exclude me
yeah yeah i think him did you talk to
you want me to you remember that oh wait
was this I wasn't paying attention all
right let's just say no oh yeah
evidently knobs clearly we could rewind
time you continually knock in the door
forever a what it seems cruel no [ __ ]
way and I still did that no it's crap oh
that was maybe we shouldn't spend so
much time knocking on people's doors
even close oh we not to go to the
principal I was Nathan oh right so
wasn't Victoria yeah that makes more
sense actually alright that's also more
scary well it's nice that he's at least
gone to the effort I like her there's
just like a random drink in the corner
as well ok gotta have that hand with a
side of sprite with open yeah being bad
other than blacks are away
it away keep frame frame yeah exactly
frame defiance well we had well
yesterday we had photography remember
why is math lab i read that his meth lab
haha monday lunch then the meth lab cook
some crystal yeah hey Kate I brought
your book max why did you step in
between David and me yesterday I hate
Billy's I hate bullies I should have
asked you safe David nuts all right no
better I also hate bullies can hide now
don't you make choices without me ever
he goes I'm sorry said Kate I actually
do care let's not go straight to video I
feel like that's insensitive we ask why
are we partied with them yeah or door
should we ask it yeah straight to the
party with them I went to a vortex Club
party against my better judgment not my
scene at all she has a hamster you know
how humiliating this is for me I know
this very Kate but tell me about the
video and maybe I can help basically I
went to one vortex Club party and ended
up making out with a bunch of people and
I have something like she's been drugged
sep did somebody drugged you you're
being a viral video sub uh every video
makes bar video camp before you came to
work with me yeah i mean against but man
Nathan Prescott he would take me to the
hot rod on I'll talk about Oh Oh Nathan
Prescott he's involved I reckon he
drugged her Nathan Prescott oh [ __ ] he
was being nice for a change when he
offered to help me I thought it was a
doctor until I heard Nathan and felt a
sharp sting in my neck once what did he
abduct her and hand and that's all I
remember I don't know what happened I
woke up outside my dorm room the next
date Nathan Prescott sounds like he
might be a psycho considering he did
that to Khloe as well remember it it was
yeah he drugged her to you yeah you
think he's implanting like microchips in
their necks or something that's what I
thought with you she said like a spike
in her neck what wasn't well yeah he's
drugging them but like wasn't he he was
taking pictures of Chloe wasn't he so
yeah maybe he's just a complete pervert
should I go to the police Oh a big
decision there well the problem is that
we had with Nathan Prescott last time we
dubbed him in is that everyone is on
like everyone's in his pocket protected
by his money so i think i think look for
pretty go the police we're gonna need
proof yeah all right lake for proof if
you do that they won't believe you smart
you're on video grabbing it all those
guys and don't use that against you bad
but not right so if that tornado cuz it
was gonna come on calls with people
calling me a viral [ __ ] thanks back
Jesus we're trying to help see this is
the same attitude I go for my last time
we helping this girl that's a supportive
aunty Wow ah but look at that hand right
beautiful macula no said I think I
should pass the control to you now okay
over to you all right all right well
let's rewind everything you've done
hahaha I'm she Westbrook she's like I
don't have to say max oh she's such a I
don't like her it's a friendly place
yeah he's photography and have a great
time come to black white hey welcome to
black hell oh that was great thanks for
the backup thanks Madge hi Taylor hi
Taylor just because you were nice to
Victoria doesn't mean I have to be like
kick her in the face is that an option I
like that her name is taylor and she
kinda looks like Taylor Swift that's not
fine don't wanna fly music is really
great Victoria but instead of smack talk
let's let's just toss just shake it off
what yeah you're funny this is a message
let you know that attempts that slander
black my own my son will be met with
many lawyers and legal ramifications
you're not the first unit blackwell to
try this I hope you're the last consider
this a final polite warning meaning
there's further impolite warnings to
come pretty much yeah Warren's much
greater how's your face what are you
doing here
oh nothing waiting hanging out with my
black eye I mean I already took the call
anyway I wanted to rap about that action
yesterday even though you left me with
said bully and ran off with that girl
yeah yeah how do you know that driving
is having a 70s minute really wants
taking on a day to the driver late yeah
let's go nice he's a chiro exactly what
I need me David talking to nathan cannot
be a good thing take a photo takes has
something to do with Kaitlyn taillights
fighters or Rachel Oh Chloe Victoria or
max no wait that's me see whales diner
hmm 24 hours get a whale burger right
now Arcadia Bay just isn't the same
fishing town I grew up in brooke has you
fished all the whales how's the town
changed much by Neptune's beard it has
hmm give you like a lawyer time ago when
I was king of the harbor oh the fish
used to jump onto my boat she's official
Scott's really did my name's wasn't much
of a fisherman to be honest for these
the Prescotts have a lot of power they
might rename the town Prescott Bay that
tells you much so you know Chloe sadly
we all know Chloe down to the station
poor George just heard the Chloe even
head oh let's go his mom all right all
right so he's talking to the potty oh
that's because I took the blame for the
pot oh yeah in that situation so he's
talking about me that's not good I'm not
big thing I have to go yeah now I just
say who told you this let's find out oh
who told you that I didn't hear it on
the police scanner Joyce said the we
belong to Chloe's friend but I highly
doubt that smiley smart off are you hmm
she wouldn't afraid I'd go arrest
somebody as if I would change the music
change music what do they have uh
cha-ching Khloe's coming I was hoping
you could be a good influence in her
life now
I will be Lily you no choice little do
you know I know things were hard for you
and khloe i feel bad i didn't call
expulsion running away drugs bad boys
tattoos piercings glue hey new Harry's a
bad sign now she's got a rebel against
her stepfather I see why I mean do you
he's not as much of a hard-ass as you
think well he did hit uh did tell you
how to join right you took that
responsibility well even hit her in my
womb ah well he fully smacked her in the
face in my one he does care about her
along with all the students at blackwell
who oh yeah let's do it yeah cares about
Kate Marsh I saw him arguing with Kate I
thought you might know why nice try
Nancy Drew but next to you there's only
one student I'm worried about and she's
not even in school anymore so now let's
get down to the nitty-gritty what do you
want to eat pancakes pancakes an option
yeah waffles close enough no Elgin
waffle okay this can be a major
consequence italian-english bankrupt
because ruins are the waffles probably
the hardest decision so far in the air
was I mean we're talking well big bacon
is this like bacon made from Bigfoot
that's just pick up his only like one of
them what belgium waffle did we get
though because look belgian waffle with
fried fish uh-huh what there's no fish
on that wall still can't believe confirm
when I look at pictures of Chloe ah
giving the devil you only get one damn
slice of bacon today whoa but you killed
that whole baked food what a waste oh
yeah sorry muffin gets a big picture how
does this [ __ ] on the jukebox oh it's
the guitar tune fine put on the banjo
then I want to love you can point out on
top of this how do you prove this oh I'd
say past we'll start slow so here I
don't you get her to tell you a secret
there's no way you could know ya know
you whine tides yeah or even draw a
thing yeah or draw things good let me
see Oh or what's in your pockets okay
it's no excuse beyond epic fails you
even made me want to believe you all
right let's realigned okay max study
every item carefully and don't please
with the bear he's with a bear
cigarettes coins this is a warning
ticket a Parkington we probably should
you know me well time but what is the
exact time I was busted falls um I'm
gonna say it was 11 10 am-11 10am that
is so dad yes dad and ask yak we go oh
god I was more than 25 cents cuz a few
coins and she's probably an I've least a
quarter let's say eighty six cents go
for a six eighty six cents yes well done
live in large and Arcadia Bay well she
doesn't seem very impressed no maybe she
is not amazeballs oh she literally just
got chills all over my neck okay what
could we do I will predict the future no
that's pretty good that's pretty good I
would look over TV Oh drunk awake
another cup really no retail for you a
refill now I gotta take this call leave
my breakfast a call hey where is my
partner partner don't slap me [ __ ] take
your fight club outside he started it I
had a fine finishing it mm-hmm man lil
all happened in those moments how
convenient and then crazy ladies up
what's she doing she went in the
bathroom crazy lady in the bathroom
oh this song very sure the hell better
than that other garbage you came on I
think God you Fox is headed for Davy
Jones's Locker the Jeep box is nearly
broken what are you waiting for okay I
should rewind until Chloe oh yeah here
we go here we get me bring it Justin and
Trevor are mighty and Joyce breaks it up
this is getting good can't wait to see
what happens Lamar I'm pretty sure all
that stuff would have happened by now
yeah now I should rewind and taupe oh we
got the last one wrong so what actually
doesn't either a fly or a cockroach went
in it LOL croch yeah alright so rewind
all the way to the Battle of debugger
okay we got this now we got this thing
no you ain't you this oh yeah when you
get it right you see that's good oops
did you break another cup oh no mom no
refill to ya I pledge allegiance to max
and the power for which she stands this
isn't a toy Chloe I do have to be
careful how i use this crew vet of
course it's a toy the best toy ever you
can bang anyone with no strings attached
rewind time and boom it's like it never
happened grow up jame to keep I never
considered that I knew before that's why
they're too high Oh God got your nose
too much blow too much notice that the
end of Ronnie trying to shake it's all
that blood see what happens when we hook
up again then let's go to one of my
secret lairs and fully test your power
and really a sight kill you okay girl
wonder finish your damn huawei to
Chloe's oh man I'm so hungry let's go to
my secret place don't even answer we
have places to go and I see how you roll
so go ahead chat up Kate Marsh from
blackwell I've got other people to hang
out what well oh you know what I'm all
right answer it and I'm donut sir I want
I don't want a donut sir I'm like I'm
sticky cake well can you don't answer it
find out what she needs
this is made what's up please don't let
your best friend get in the way you okay
I'm chillin with you okay for now let's
rock geez cheer up epic opens town is so
miserable you're right it sucks the
Chloe and Joyce got into an argument I
could rewind and no answer Katie exactly
what I got a date exactly can won't see
you in class later you going haha not
this time Kate Marsh tough luck later
mom by choice all right this is made
freedom I feel bad about Kate no I did
she'll survive you not taking that one
call troop she will unless she's a
terrible danger power and rule the world
cheer up he doesn't get upset I didn't
answer but I could rewind and answer her
oh he's this weekend
you